but alright so that's that talk to your
wife yeah talk to your wife she watch
anything else is that it you won
yesterday I got drunk with a known and
only friend and end up fooling around
I spoke beforehand a big game about my
sex drive but when it came down to it I
couldn't get it up I am twin classy and
I feel quite embarrassed what's the
worst is that I what's worst I like the
girl I'm afraid she might see me as less
of a man how do you think I should go
about this how many yeah come on Bobby
speaking from experience you've been
there a few times on I think it's porn
erectile dysfunction I read an article
in Men's Journal that there's a
phenomenon called erectile important
because they're so used to see you and I
want to live up to that and it makes
them well they stated it's oversaturated
when we were young in high school right
we didn't have the internet I don't know
if you did but I didn't write no so you
and I if we wanted to watch any kind of
pornography we see you trade magazines
or there would be a field and you'd open
up oh lift up a rock yeah yeah weird
wolf kid that I hung out with and I went
around to his house yeah I'm Jerusalem
I'm knock on the door
oh yeah weirdo Gino Panaro Angie
Michaels here and floor-to-ceiling porno
Wow everyone yeah in the world crazy so
if I wanted my porn figs yeah I just
went on to Aziz house but now kids right
have everything yeah push of a button
yeah it's crazy right high school kids
can watch its wiring a pornography that
they can watch and they're so inundated
with it that it [ __ ] with them
psychologically and then when they're
with a real woman sometimes they can't
get erect experience is just not up to
par yeah you know they present sex is
like this super it meant sex in real
life especially when you're young kid is
super awkward it's clumsy
it's just don't really know how your
body moves in that way and when you're
watching you know you can't live up to
that expectation of what you see
but if you like the girl enough I know
it would take off without feeling of
awkwardness yeah the little man takes
over the big man but years ago I was in
Toronto before way before you bet I
remember the story you told me all your
sexual ask yeah and there was a woman in
my hotel room
she was beautiful beautiful she
completely naked laying on my bed and I
could take my clothes off and I read but
that month had been just just jerking
off to every kind of [ __ ] porn you
know I mean all J old you know yeah all
kinds of stuff right wrinkly wrinkly
vaginas all that stuff right and let me
just do it right I can see your hands I
know yourself so hard no I was doing
this might be a bit longer this time a
whole month and when I finally you know
when this girl was in front of me in
this hotel room I just couldn't get it
up you know and um I just think that had
that has a lot to do with it yeah I mean
I mean what kind of man are we talking
about here yeah I know what kind of man
are we talking proper man are we talking
about someone that might be you know you
know maybe say well no I'm talking about
an alpha male I've never had a problem
with anything like that in my life and
I'm not trying to sound hard or at all
for [ __ ] mr. top man yeah you know
but I want to say this not everybody has
the same amount of testosterone went
into the body I would assume you know I
mean that's why some people like myself
fight in the UFC and challenge himself
and do things like that because we're
driven and we're built a certain way you
know and then this young man here you
know maybe he's more what's the office I
can tell women positive oh man any scars
[Laughter]
I'm gonna just prove that theory because
I don't know there's this guy that I did
remember before you the guy from England
yeah
and young boxer right oh he could get it
up and not because it was it not it was
he just couldn't get it up I don't know
why or how or maybe he was on subs
supplements and I don't know what but he
was an alpha male yeah but what does
alpha milk just tell me what an alpha
male is and he's like he's I don't know
the scientific what am i beta
here's a dictionary yeah yeah go ahead
the dominant male animal in a particular
group yeah so when you're coyotes they
have the head guy sure leader of the
pack leader of the pack that's the Alpha
man he likes the [ __ ] well you're so
because he's the alpha male he liked it
[ __ ] he gets about hey little guy he
wants to [ __ ] to the little one
don't do this okay yeah
la Llorona is alpha and Ryan come on
yeah I don't think I'm an alpha male but
I feel like at in certain circle anymore
you are you are in your own way I'm not
talking physicalities because that's not
important thank you no no no for sure
chunk thank you no you are the alpha
male of this group 100% you you're the
namesake of the podcast you're the
[ __ ] fancy comedian yeah there's this
big swinging day
until a real alpha male walks in you
know and then you know I'm not the new
leader
I'm a lone wolf yeah so maybe he's not
an alpha male
no no what he's saying maybe he's not
maybe he's not highly sexed we also
don't know what he's like
that's what I'm saying what if you use
an alpha my buddy was molested brutally
as a kid yeah you don't know you don't
know also how much sometimes like I feel
like he wouldn't provide the question
it's anonymous he doesn't know faces
yeah yeah I was raped as a child but a
lot of people don't say it a lot of
people don't say even if it's anonymous
they've hidden it so deep right that you
know they don't they don't even know
they can't cause they're not aware of a
memory but it happened at 23 were you
able to talk about like your sexual like
mala stations and all of that no two
people you are oh yeah so you were just
out there with it why were you were you
a victim of sexual assault stands to
reason I knew it I went out of this one
alive
I was weirdly sexual growing up and you
know I don't know I you know I don't
want to doubt tell us to Mike but you
know I've even had you know yeah
appearances with the opposite the same
sex sure okay as a kid yeah but um but
yeah I mean but I my fing is porn
definitely so I'm just saying that this
guy I know what my when I have issues
like that it has to do with porn and
yeah so he's put too much well you're
saying too much strange do you watch
porn yeah I mean occasionally I'm you
know when you're on the road wife and
three kids probably watch there's all my
gonna sit there and [ __ ] break down
my porn huh
[Music]